even on a journey to space there comes
that moment when you're squeezed into
the back of a car it was fitting perhaps
that at the wheel was jeff bezos the man
making william shatner's space dream
come true
more than 50 years after he first talked
of space as that final frontier science
fiction about to become reality taking
his seat inside the capsule atop the new
shepard rocket on the verge of becoming
the oldest person ever in space
two
one
[Music]
they rocketed up more than 60 miles to
the edge of space
the prize the view of earth and a few
minutes of the weightlessness of zero
gravity
it was all over within minutes 3 600
feet or about 1200 meters above ground
level let's wait for that now the drag
breaks have deployed
first the rocket returning safely to
earth
[Music]
that was unlike anything they described
again
and then with a few words of celebration
the capsule
and capsule touchdown
shatner and his three fellow crew
members now officially recognized as
astronauts
the debate about whether this is just a
game for billionaires and their friends
whether tackling problems on earth
should be the priority rages for a
clearly emotional shatner what he saw up
there he believes can do good down here
what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can imagine
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary extraordinary
the companies involved in this new space
race say people are queuing up for the
chance to experience that and they've
collected millions of dollars in
advanced ticket sales but whatever the
talk of democratizing space it will
remain a long way out of reach for most
of us but every successful mission is a
pr victory
it's my real honor to pin this on you a
man who for generations of people
represented what space was has now seen
the real thing how many more of us will
ever get to boldly go where william
shatner's been greg milam sky news texas